David se ha visto afectado desde el
comienzo de la invasión a gran escala el
pasado 24 de febrero incluso desde el
comienzo se habló que uno de los
objetivos del presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin no solamente era entrar y tomar
todo el control del Zurdo Ucrania
incluido la ciudad de odesa sino abrir
un corredor que llegara también hasta
este pequeño país tal vez el más pobre
de Europa que está al lado de esa región
controlada también por la fuerza rusas
de transnistria esto no ha sido así pero
se ha visto afectado enormemente no
solamente por la escasez de Electricidad
de gas y también por la gran inflación
que ha habido y también por el flujo de
refugiados sino por las crisis políticas
días atrás tuvo que renunciar la primera
ministra como consecuencia de estos
graves problemas sociales Aunque
realmente quien tiene el poder en el
país es la presidenta Maya salud que
está desde el 2020 y un bloque Pro
europeísta esto contrario a quienes
gobernaban el país
anteriormente que estaban más vinculados
con el presidente Putin y con ese bloque
ex soviético Así que es continúa la
crisis en este país después de un año lo
que nos cuenta la población es que los
precios han subido altísimo que ellos se
han visto afectados por la guerra y como
el resto esperan que esta termine pronto
porque piensan que realmente están
pagando un alto precio pero también
piensan que si Ucrania no resiste esto
tendrá grandes consecuencias para
moldavia especialmente para ese bloque
de la población que espera a ser parte
de la Unión Europea en un futuro